in this lesson we're gonna cover four
methods for getting this one Ford IX
relationship and so we're going to have
two functional groups that are on the 1
& 4 carbon atoms of whatever molecule
that we have so let's look at two
methods to make dicarbonyl compounds
with this relationship take this
compound for example if we number our
carbons we see that each of these
carbonyl groups is on the 1 & 4 position
so now we need to break a bond we need
to think about this retro synthetically
if we cleave between carbons 2 & 3 we
can trace this back to a couple synth
ons so now we need to assign polarities
this is a secondary carbon atom and so
I'm going to assign this as the negative
partner and hopefully this will make
sense in just a second now that we've
assigned our polarities we need to trace
back to reagents the first one is simple
it's just cyclohexanone that we analyzed
but here we have a cation and so what we
need to do is introduce some sort of a
leaving group but hey that's a pretty
good thing too because we know that we
can analyze and put a halogen right next
to a carbonyl alpha to a carbonyl
smoothly in in an enol ization reaction
so having a leaving group here will give
that positive character so we might
envision this coming from this bromide
now we chose to make the secondary
carbon here our enolate and this one was
our positive partner that is because
enol a alkylations work much better with
primary alkyl halides so if we had the
secondary bromide and tried to displace
it with the enolate of this we would get
significant elimination the reaction
would be slow and so it's really best in
your alkylations stick to primary
halides now Eataly alkylations aren't
really that great of a reaction they
don't always go very smoothly there are
a few synthetic equivalence of this
compound that work much better in this
reaction let's take a look at those
first of all we have ena means one issue
with enolates in general is that they
have resonance that puts the negative
charge on oxygen and so sometimes they
can alkylate a carbon and sometimes that
oxygen inna means tend to make this
reaction more smooth and then they're
just hydrolyzed after the reaction to
form the ketones just to illustrate the
initial arrow pushing the nitrogen will
push in the lone pair this double bond
can attack at the carbon displacing
bromine now we have this iminium ion
when treated with water and acid water
will attack here you can show a few
proton transfers and elimination of your
amine to give a carbonyl compound back
another synthetic equivalent that
superior is this dicarbonyl compound
here we have this other ester so we can
alkylate and we'll add a carbon so we'll
have a carbon co o T added here these
are much more acidic at this proton so
easier to deprotonate under more mild
conditions they alkylate fairly smoothly
and then they can be decarboxylated to
remove this group so we can use these as
partners in these reactions as well
let's take this count on again and
envision a different disconnection say
we cleave the molecule here this might
seem like a bit of a weird disconnection
at first because we're chopping off this
functionality but there is a synthetic
equivalent to this now let's look at our
sentence starting with just this side if
we take this and remember the natural
polarity is a negative here and so one
carbon away the natural polarity for a
synth on is positive and this can be
envisioned as coming from the Ino n--
now what is there going to be our
equivalent of this we need a synth on
that's the equivalent of a one carbon
negative and that's actually going to be
the cyanide anion so this is the
equivalent of one carbon with a negative
charge on it so we could add cyanide in
a conjugate addition fashion but how are
we going to get the ester out of this
it's actually a pretty smooth
let's check it out we may warm this to
promote our conjugate addition and we'll
get this product and now nitriles can
undergo hydrolysis reactions and
hydrolysis in general just in water will
give the carboxylic acid but if we carry
this out Witt using acid in an alcoholic
solvent like methanol or ethanol will
produce the corresponding methyl or
ethyl ester so the reaction looks like
this and I meant to write ethyl but I
wrote methyl so let's just hydrolyze
this to the methyl ester and we'll be
very close to this product just changing
out the solvent here will give you the
ethyl ester so our product will now be
this methyl ester here let's say our
synthetic target is a hydroxy ketone
maybe something like this we'll number
our atoms to reveal our 1 4 relationship
and now we're going to cleave in such a
way that we produce an enolate from this
side so again cleaving between carbon
atoms 2 & 3 so here's our enolate and
we're going to make a positive synth on
from this other side so let's look at
what that looks like oxygen has lone
pairs if we envision it using one of
them to make a bond with this
electrophilic site we reveal an epoxy ID
and you should always be using an epoxy
ID for this synthetic equivalent here
never put a chlorine or a bromine as a
leaving group here you're just gonna
have complications with deprotonating
the alcohol you'll need protecting
groups you make your synthesis more
complicated so whenever you see this
synth on here with the positive charge
adjacent to the O H that's in Epoque
side we can also get this pattern using
enolates of nitro compounds imagine
we're trying to synthesize this let's
number to reveal our 1 4 pattern and now
we need to figure out where to cleave
our bond when a nitro compound analyzes
it does so adjacent to the nitrogen and
the charge stabilizes it so we're
actually not like a normal enolate going
to cleave between two at carbons 2 & 3
we're going to now cleave between
carbons 1 &
- let's examine our synth ins here's our
nitro enolate this is super - easy to
form with just a weak base because we
have this resonance with the nitro group
our other synth on needs to be of the
opposite polarity and this is something
we're familiar with this is upside down
but we have the carbonyl and then two
carbons away we have the positive
character here's the carbonyl two
carbons away we have the positive
character so this also corresponds to an
e known
fortunately nitro enolates do conjugate
addition very well due to their
resonance stabilization so reaction of a
nitro enolate with our in own will give
our one four relationship now there
aren't a ton of natural products that
actually contain the nitro group on it
and so we might need to transform this
into something else
treatment with base and and oxidant can
give dicarbonyl compounds imagine we
reduce the nitro with say catalytic
hydrogenation now we have an amine and a
carbonyl in a 1/4 pattern once we reveal
the amine be careful because it could
cyclize onto this carbonyl depending on
what your R group is now let's discuss
one more bonus way to make this
substitution pattern and this isn't
really a disconnection so I'm not gonna
put it here but we'll just have it as a
little aside we can achieve this pattern
using alkynes okay imagine we do a
functional group interconversion here
and add an alkyne right in the center of
this molecule we'll get this now all
kinds can be deprotonated to make great
nucleophiles and so a logical place to
cleave this is next to the alkyne this
gets us back to our alkyne is the- synth
on and our positive synth on will look
like this if we again envision donation
of oxygens electrons toward that
positive charge will reveal that those
hydroxyl groups can be produced from
aldehydes so for our forward synthesis
we can react the aldehyde with the and
of an acetylide to get compounds like
this and then we can reduce these using
catalytic hydrogenation to get our 1/4
pattern on a straight chained molecule